you know I don't always advocate 3d you
know that but the last act of this movie
in 3d pretty sweet-looking
not gonna lie about that get real in the
intro my video I guess the wah could do
the walk alive do the walk of Dean it
didn't it it did it dan it whoo there's
no way to listen to that song to be
pissed it's just impossible to the walks
directed by Robert Zemeckis it stars
Joseph gordon-levitt Joseph
gordon-levitt plays a guy he's a street
performer he does high wire it's just
his passion it's what he does so he's
looking for the next big place the next
great place to hang his wire doesn't do
it for money or ego he does it for
purpose and life and so these buildings
in New York called the World Trade
Towers were being built and he was like
that's where I'm gonna hang my next wire
which is completely illegal it takes a
lot of infiltration but that's the last
act of the movie this movie was
ultimately a crock pot of different
movie elements to make this one movie
you're seeing Joseph gordon-levitt and
how we learned to do high wire he meets
this girl so you're like all right it's
kind of a romance movie bomber is the
romance doesn't always land in the movie
yes romance in a situation like this
where someone's a complete workaholic
and all he cares about is this one thing
a does cause tension which you know all
right romance is good in that sense in a
movie like this Plus this is based on a
true story so I imagine you can't just
write the girl out of it if he had a
romance with this girl who was
ultimately one of his accomplices in
doing this less there's this weird
voiceover elements not really a
voiceover it's just like cuts from the
situation entirely nice Joseph
gordon-levitt standing on the Statue of
Liberty and he is talking to the
audience he's telling you what he was
thinking and what might happen next he's
like let's check it out let's watch it
happens a few times that's the jarring
thing when we got a theater everyone you
were walking past so like this is why
was he talking the sexual urges everyone
was talking about that one element in
the movie with a question mark over
their head and I do agree it's like why
not just have Joseph gordon-levitt do
voice over telling you about the
situation but don't have him talk to the
camera the last act of this movie maybe
the last half to last third is amazing
the last after this movie focuses up
completely Joseph gordon-levitt and his
crew have to get up this tower and
secretly hang the wire and do the high
wire act without anybody knowing these
trap Metal Gear Solid their way up this
thing to make it work and you're like
this is tactical espionage operation
can't say action because it's not action
and then you
the walk you're like oh my gosh is how I
should feel in a high-wire act see I've
never seen a high-wire act up close or
in person I've seen it online I've seen
it on video and you just feel like
alright it's a video there's a
separation of reality that is where the
IMAX 3d did come in for me like any
other special effect element in the
movie it can be completely wasted or it
can add to the experience this did add
to it because when you're up there you
feel like you are up there Zemeckis does
such a good job making you feel like
these towers are here and it is 1974 and
we're up on a [ __ ] wire that's scary
[ __ ] so cool to see it's amazing and
what made it better for me is my lack of
history I guess I don't I didn't know
this story I had no idea because if you
google world trade tower history you
don't get someone walking on a high wire
these days you just don't sing this it's
just seeing the situation for the first
time for me I had no idea this guy's
story I had no idea how it was going to
go down how it was going to play out and
after this movie's done you're like how
did I not know about this guy's
reviewing this movie's pretty simple I'm
going to take you through it like this
Joseph gordon-levitt was great in the
movie his romance with the girl as a
romance it's fine it's serviceable but
it doesn't steal the show or anything
like that I like the supporting cast I
like the supporting crew I like when the
plan focuses up in that I like the
second half much better than the first
half the first half kind of trucks along
you're alright let's get to the second
half the second half of this movies
everything you like about a heist movie
without them actually stealing [ __ ] just
achieving those hopes and dreams and
becoming the thing of legend that I
never heard of until I saw those movies
the last act of this movie is a
spectacle and a testament as to why
movies are made I just wish the rest of
the movie felt that great but in the end
I will say the walk is worth buying on
blu-ray right guys the walk have you
seen it what did you think about it do
the walk of life whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more